well
[Music]
is one of the headlines for today thursday
october 29 this morning the last
resort that is still closed on the
las vegas strip will reopen to the public
rightly plans a
reopening ceremony to welcome
tourists and locals from  10 in
the morning
this will be suitable for people over 21 with the
exception of the restaurant
the varied show will arrive adsense returned
to the spirals site last night for the first time since
march several changes were implemented
due to the pandemic the capacity is
limited and has a new system
to filter the air inside the venue
the busiest airline at the local airport will
now connect las vegas' with another
city juárez launched direct trips
twice daily between las vegas' and colorado
springs starting in march the airline will
celebrate this premiere with an
exclusive offer  from 59 dollars for one way flights
now we turn to the
weather forecast we will be around 80 degrees
by today Thursday  we will remain with
pleasant and warm temperatures for
the rest of the week on tuesday
we will have an official or sunny election day
in the valley have a nice day
and take care I am héctor mejía and this was
your brief informative broadcast in
spanish
[Music]